Submarines are supposed to be totally
undetectable. That's their whole M.O.. They sneak
around the world's oceans being undetectable,
they carry nuclear weapons... But one way that
adversaries try to find submarines is through
magnets. Because submarines are giant hunks of
metal, you can fly one of these little airplanes
over the ocean looking for some magnetic field
coming from the sub. This is not good. Submarines
need to stay stealthy. Oh, and did I mention that
there are these underwater mines that look like
they should be in some video game? They respond
to magnetism. So if a submarine is sneaking in
its enemies waters and it floats next to one of
these mines, it could trip the mine if it's giving
out too much magnetism. So the Navy's solution?
The magnetism carwash. Before the subs go out on
deployment, they run it through this like, carwash
thing and they get rid of all the magnetism and
the sort of magnetic field fingerprints to make
it way less likely to be detectable. And then they
go out on their way. I’ve been deep in submarines
because we just made this super long video and
it's like a super deep dive into submarines– Deep
dive. I just said “deep dive” when talking about
submarines. Yep, I'm gonna sign off now, bye.